I'm probably overfitting but it seems to
me that many of the sessions so far have
had kind of three talks that fell under
a unifying theme and then one outlier
and in my subjective view that's been
good so far and got an interesting
crosstalk going so I think the unifying
theme as far as I can tell this session
is really about learning and predicting
various things in networks art is going
to start off by talking about label
prediction in networks where you have
partially labeled in partial labels in
the graph and you want to make
inferences for nearby labels from
various similarity metrics like the
laplacian and the like then i think a
lot is next and she's going to talk
instead about trying to predict
cascading behavior and contagion in
networks jan is then going to talk about
inference and relationships between
social networks and graphical models
which we heard a little bit about from
Kozma yesterday somewhat negatively for
causal purposes but i think the news in
terms of inference might be a little bit
rosier and then my perceived outliers
Damon who's probably still working on
his slide somewhere who's going to talk
about interesting online experiments on
social norms and my suspect he it may
have things to say about the difficulty
of predicting the emergence of social
norms and networks and and then we'll
have as usual of a open discussion
following so with that let me go ahead
and turn it over to art